Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Tengo un temita con la verdad
y con las conversaciones.
Me formé como científica
pero terminé tomando caminos extraños.
La ciencia es una manera
de hacerle preguntas al mundo
y de escuchar sus respuestas.
Nunca sabremos todo.
Pero eso no quiere decir
que no sepamos nada.
Hay mucho que ya sabemos.
Sin embargo, la evidencia
a veces es dejada de lado
a la hora de tomar decisiones
o de formarnos una imagen del mundo.
Por ejemplo, ya sabemos que
el cambio climático es una realidad,
pero hay quienes lo niegan.
Ya sabemos que las vacunas
funcionan y son seguras.
Pero también hay quienes dudan.
Esa fue mi primera decepción:
Las evidencias son necesarias
pero no suficientes.
Con esto se me abrió un nuevo camino.
Pensé que el problema era la educación.
Así que dejé el laboratorio
y me dediqué a enseñar.
Amo la docencia.
El aula es uno de mis lugares preferidos.
Pero ahí encontré
el mismo problema que antes.
Estaba enseñando sobre vacunas
y una estudiante dijo
que ella no se vacunaba
porque las vacunas le parecían peligrosas.
Mi intuición fue:
"Dice esto porque no sabe del tema,
si le explico, va a cambiar su postura".
Le expliqué, pero no funcionó.
La evidencia no alcanza.
La educación no alcanza.
Segunda decepción.
Esto que me pasó con mi estudiante
fue mi primera experiencia personal
con la post-verdad.
Eso que pasa cuando,
aunque la información esté,
se deja de lado y se siguen
las emociones o las creencias.
Con esto se abrió un nuevo camino.
¿Será un problema de comunicación?
Como la ciencia es una herramienta,
la usé para estudiar la post-verdad.
Empecé a conversar con personas
que desconfían de las vacunas
y a encontrarme con médicos y periodistas
para tratar de mejorar
la comunicación sobre el tema.
Y ahí entendí que nunca
había aprendido a conversar
con los que piensan distinto.
Por ejemplo:
¿cómo dialogamos cuando
el problema no es la evidencia
sino un desacuerdo ideológico?
Hay experimentos que muestran
que cuando la gente conversa
solamente con los que piensan igual
sus opiniones se vuelven
más extremas y homogéneas.
Pero para tener una democracia saludable
¿no necesitamos que
los que piensan distinto
logren conversaciones
amplias, honestas y profundas?
Esto no es lo que está pasando.
Cada discusión, cada desacuerdo,
cada conversación,
parece una batalla entre el bien y el mal.
Nuestras opiniones,
en vez de ser provisorias,
puentes para comunicarnos
con otros, son inamovibles,
una zanja que cavamos y que separa
a los que están de nuestro lado
de los otros.
El diálogo desaparece,
el acuerdo es imposible,
y el mundo se fragmenta
en una combinación explosiva
de agresión y desconfianza.
¿Podemos hacer algo?
No todas las opiniones nacen iguales.
Algunas son débiles, o temporarias.
Otras son intensas, o duraderas.
Y otras se vuelven
parte de nuestra identidad.
Cuando pasa eso, cualquier duda
sobre lo que pensamos
se vuelve una duda
acerca de quiénes somos.
Y eso nos resulta insoportable.
Además, la necesidad
de proteger nuestra integridad
nos hace agruparnos con los
que están en la misma situación.
Esto es el tribalismo.
Por eso a veces ni la evidencia
ni la educación funcionan.
No pensamos algo, somos ese algo.
(Aplausos)
Les hago una pregunta:
¿Les pasó alguna vez
de ir a una reunión social
en donde hay personas que
no conocen y pensar algo como
"Mmm, no sé qué piensa esta gente,
mejor de tal tema no hablo"?
¿Les pasó?
A ver, levanten la mano
los que vivieron algo así.
Mírense.
El daño del tribalismo no es solo que
genera un clima de conflicto permanente,
sino también que genera silencios.
Algunos nos retiramos del debate
pero no porque no tengamos opiniones
o no nos importe lo que pasa.
No somos tibios.
Por el clima de agresión,
porque las cosas no avanzan,
por miedo, por hartazgo,
por la penalización social del disenso,
por uno o varios de estos motivos,
abandonamos la conversación en silencio.
Es un silencio ruidoso.
Y así, la imposibilidad de dialogar
hace que el número de voces disminuya.
A veces hasta que queda una sola.
Se confunde silencio con asentimiento.
Y se crea una ilusión de consenso.
Como se oye una sola opinión,
parece que hay una sola opinión.
Y entonces cualquier otra opinión
ya no es solamente distinta,
es disonante, es ajena,
y debe ser eliminada.
En general, asociamos la idea de censura
con la de un poder
que prohíbe desde arriba.
Pero hay otra forma más sutil.
La censura desde abajo.
La que a través de herramientas
de disciplinamiento social,
como por ejemplo subiendo el tono
de la pelea, genera que nos retiremos.
Esto es una amenaza a la libre expresión.
Y me hace pensar que también
es un problema para la democracia.
Tanto en nuestro pequeño entorno
como a gran escala.
Parecería entonces
que hay solo dos opciones.
O mostramos nuestras ideas despreciando
a los que no piensan como nosotros,
o nos callamos.
Y al hacer eso cedemos el control
a los que deciden hablar.
Pero esto es un falso dilema.
Hay otra opción,
pero necesitamos volverla evidente
porque está oculta
en este mar de tribalismo.
Podemos tener posturas definidas,
incluso muy intensas,
sin subirnos a la dinámica
del discurso intolerante.
Es una de las cosas que aprendí
al hablar con las personas
que dudan de las vacunas.
Para romper con el tribalismo,
para buscar la mayor cantidad de voces,
para salir de esta dinámica
de amigos y enemigos,
propongo distinguir entre
qué creemos y cómo lo creemos.
Y si a este cómo lo volvemos no tribal,
podemos plantear nuestras opiniones
sin que lo que pensamos
se convierta en lo que somos.
Reaparecen los matices
y las conversaciones se vuelven posibles.
Y a partir de ahí
se pueden construir consensos
que son producto de lograr acuerdos
a pesar de nuestras diferencias.
Pero cuando hablo de estas ideas
me suelen hacer algunas críticas.
Por ejemplo, que parece que
con tal de evitar los conflictos
planteo dejar que los consensos
decanten donde sea.
No, no es eso lo que quiero decir.
Si no nos expresamos porque
nos sentimos alienados o expulsados
no estamos participando
de la toma de decisiones.
Pero todos vivimos con
las consecuencias de esas decisiones.
Entonces, como no nos da todo lo mismo,
necesitamos hablar.
Pero si no queremos hablar
en este clima hostil porque nos agota
y vemos que no lleva a nada,
tratemos de superar el modo tribal.
Más allá de lo que pensemos.
Quizá tengamos más en común
con quienes piensan distinto
pero quieren conversar
que con los que comparten con nosotros
alguna opinión pero son intolerantes.
(Aplausos)
También me suelen decir
que no hay mucho que podamos hacer
a nivel individual
para salir del modo tribal.
Pero me parece que sí
hay cosas para hacer, bien concretas.
Y tengo tres sugerencias
que podrían ayudar.
Primero, buscar el pluralismo.
Promoverlo activamente.
Así el disenso se vuelve visible
y esto es importante porque
solo si incluimos el disenso
podemos lograr un verdadero consenso.
Para que esto pueda pasar
necesitamos poder hablar
sin sentir que
se nos penaliza socialmente.
Pero también hace falta
que seamos capaces
de escuchar voces que no nos gustan.
El momento de defender
la libertad de expresión es ahora.
Cuidarla es más fácil que recuperarla.
Aprender a conversar mejor.
A encontrar mejores maneras
de estar en desacuerdo.
Conversar no es esperar
nuestro turno para hablar,
tratando de imponer nuestras ideas
por la fuerza o la insistencia.
Es escuchar para entender al otro.
Sin escucha no hay conversación.
Tercero, separar las ideas
de las personas.
Bajo el tribalismo, atacar una idea
hace que la persona se sienta amenazada
porque siente que
se la ataca como persona.
Pero con esa actitud, ¿cómo vamos
a lograr mejorar las ideas?
Necesitamos discutirlas
para que sobrevivan las mejores.
Las personas merecen respeto.
Las ideas tienen que ganárselo.
Los humanos somos inventores.
En algún punto, en algún lugar,
inventamos la idea de sentarnos
junto al fuego a conversar.
Y en un punto, las conversaciones
y el fuego se parecen.
Los dos están siempre entre dos peligros.
El de extinguirse y el de crecer
de modo descontrolado.
Nos llevó tiempo pero
aprendimos a usar el fuego.
Aprendimos a mantenerlo vivo
para que no se apague.
Y a manejarlo para que no nos destruya.
Quizá llegó la hora de aprender
a hacer lo mismo con las conversaciones.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)